talk now you seem upset
well here's how the story goes remember
that little Halloween bet that we made
you probably don't even remember it was
so early this morning
anyhoo zl-- it turns out the criminal I
hired to lift your watch was not
trustworthy and I ended up contracting
tuberculosis of the foot and
subsequently losing your death watch but
in the end I like to think this whole
thing is gonna bring us closer together
and isn't that what it's really all
about Merry Christmas
what are you saying my watch is right
here no I made a switch that's a fake no
this one's a fake what no what no what
no you were behind all this you played
me like awesome blue hime plays the
flute but how I've been planning this
theft for three months I know but I've
been planning it for a year
last Halloween after you won the bed I
went back to my office to do everyone's
paperwork but I did no paperwork I
started to plot my revenge
I began by creating a word and club but
how could you possibly have known I was
gonna try and steal your watch I know
you were trying to take something
important to me during the year I drew
your attention to my watch you're eight
minutes late
you're 14 minutes late you're three
minutes early in Chicago
you annoyed me into stealing it exactly
now you had a target but you needed a
plan fortunately and walk through the
door handcuffed to Diaz scumbag
pickpocket is Dan McCreary you take
anything off of anyone anything anyone
the look on your face priceless
I put McCreary into my employee
immediately fast forward to this morning
you commenced your plan McCreary stole
my watch and then replaced it with the
replica and while you celebrated
McCreary put my launch back in my pocket
the watch never left my person dead
I can see that you're enjoying this not
nearly as much as I enjoyed phase to do
while you met with McCreary Santiago
placed a fire hydrant in front of your
car which she then to hold away next I
had to take Charles out of the equation
he had a badge and a gun and he would do
anything to help you enter a parade of
drunks that separated the two of you
long enough for Kerry to kidnap Charles
then two bears spilled their drinks on
you and stole your wallet those bears
Scully and Hitchcock if Terry kidnapped
Charles how did Charles tell me to get
on the party of us eight months ago at a
morning briefing I told the squad that a
group of thieves was targeting party
buses so I could record Charles saying
Jake party bus a new Boyle would never
knowingly betrayed me with your jacket
and shoes gone you didn't look like a
cop but you still had your badge that is
until you entered the party bus Rosa's
feline dancing distracted you as a
mysterious partier stole your badge on
you in the mask you sly son of a [ __ ]
well done but I do have to ask those
guys at the impound
did they really smash my car no in fact
I had them wash it good one captain you
can't wash a car so how'd you convince
the whole squad to betray me what did
you offer them I asked them if they
wanted to embarrass you and they can
simply say yes not gonna lie that turns
me off a little bit
so in addition to the five weeks of free
overtime I believe I'm owed one more
thing yes here we go 1:30 very well
captain Raymond Holt you are an amazing
police captain / genius but be warned I
started planning next year's heist just
this minute good then you're only three
months behind
you